>>> I AM RACHEL CAMPO, IN FOR
LAURA INGRAHAM. THIS IS A
SPECIAL EDITION OF "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" LIVE FROM NEW
YORK CITY TONIGHT. REMEMBER
WHEN THEY TOLD US ABOUT JOE
BIDEN.
>> JOE BIDEN IS THE MOST
EXPERIENCED FOREIGN POLICY
EXPERT SINCE GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
>> BIDEN IS DOING EVERYTHING HE
CAN TO REASSURE AMERICAN GLOBAL
WORLD LEADERSHIP IS COMING
BACK.
>> HE'S THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE.
>> NOT SO MUCH.
>> THERE WAS THE AFGHANISTAN
PULL-OUT. CAVING TO CHINA AND
OF COURSE THE DANGEROUS, NEVER
ENDING WAR IN UKRAINE. BIDEN
HAS TURNED OUR COUNTRY INTO A
DORMANT FOR CHINA AND NOW IT IS
ALL ESCALATING. BIDEN WARNS
UNDER HIS WATCH, WE ARE HEADING
TO AN ARMAGEDDON. WE HAVE NOT
FACED THE PROSPECT OF
ARMAGEDDON SINCE THE KENNEDY.
HE'S NOT JOKING WHEN HE TALKS
ABOUT POTENTIAL USE OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR BIOLOGICAL
OR CHEMICAL WEAPONS. WHAT
BREAKING NEW INTEL DID THE
ADMINISTRATION RECEIVED THAT
WOULD LEAD US TO BELIEVE
ARMAGEDDON WAS IMMINENT?
>> YOU HAVE NEW INTEL?
>> NO, THE PRESIDENT WAS
SPEAKING ABOUT CONCERNS OF
PUTIN'S THREAT TO USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS JUST AS HE DID AT THE
UN GENERAL ASSEMBLY. YOU HEARD
IT OVER AND OVER FROM THE
NATIONAL SECURITY AND YOU HEARD
FROM JAK